well I'm joined Now by defense Analyst
at the Royal United Services Institute
Dr Alexandra Warmsley thanks so much for
joining us in the studio shall we start
in that cushion area what's what's
happening then what does it say about
Russia well it's very interesting that
Putin has suggested that the inhabitants
of her son evacuate this could imply
that Russia is losing control of that
territory and they're expecting
Ukrainian counter-attack but it's also
just possible that this could be a trap
or an attempt to lure the ukrainians
into a difficult position and make them
vulnerable and also Alexandra ukrainians
they're making gains
um can we talk a little bit about that
because what are we seeing that Russia
are doing because of this well the
ukrainians have been able to retake some
territory particularly towards the east
and as they reclaim these Villages and
towns we are seeing the impact of eight
and a half months of Russian occupation
where all pretense that they were going
after strategic military targets is now
abandoned when you see a church like
this in the dolnya village at absolutely
reduced to Rubble okay so yeah absolute
destruction I want to focus now on
President zielinski because he has
spoken about blackouts hasn't he after
Russia have targeted the energy Supply
what can we make of this well because
it's now getting harder to fight because
we're into the sort of Muddy season and
land land Warfare is tricky Putin is
really trying to impact as many people
in Ukraine as possible so you're seeing
blackouts as far west as ritamir as far
east as
khiven the north zeppar Asia in the
South really making day-to-day life of
ukrainians difficult because of course
everybody relies on electricity he's
hoping that this would Stoke fear and
resentment of the regime and and crack
the cohesion and unity that the
ukrainians have shown till now okay uh
Alexandra thank you very much for those
insights we appreciate it